now in the past all of the internet was
not just porn some parts out there
contained cats but recently there's been
a fluffy little uprising and dogs have
taken over the web so since we're all
about the internet we are dedicating the
entire show to the only friends that we
will willingly watch lick their own
balls and if you need proof the canines
are now top dog online according to NPR
the Internet has an entirely new
language specifically about dogs with
words like
pooper floof and blem also antisocial
nutjob who claims to be a dog person but
is really just a weirdo God so cute o-69
o-69 it get it get it yeah that is the
most adorable blowjob you will ever see
anything all right
now the dogs are the Alpha the Internet
how are they going to celebrate Derby
they're gonna celebrate the same way I
celebrate by pissing myself all right
boy okay by Dober mansplaining the way
it is to these cocker spaniel yes very
good wordplay fine Mary they're gonna
celebrate like with that scene from
risky business but sliding in on their
assholes yes boys anything in him
[Laughter]
[Applause]